[Musique]
depuis le sommet de rio nous avons connu
les dix années les plus chaudes de
l'humanité rappelez-vous la tempête de
l'hiver 99 la canicule de l'été 2003
l'ouragan katrina dans quinze ans que
répondrez vous à vos enfants quand ils
vous demanderont tu savais tu n'as rien
fait pourquoi on ne fera pas d'écologie
sans les écologistes
je suis la candidate des verts des
écologistes j'ai 48 ans je suis maman de
deux filles
mais ce n'est pas en tant que femme que
je me présente aux élections
présidentielles je suis médecin
j'ai été militant syndical militantes
associatives militantes politiques au
sein des verts
je suis élue de seine-saint-denis j'ai
été ministre
je veux à chaque instant concilier
l'action sur le terrain et le changement
des politiques depuis 20 ans l'écologie
c'est vraiment toute ma vie je suis
professeur des écoles cette année j'ai
une classe à double niveau 1 cp cm2 en
classe nous travaillons sur la
révolution française la révolution
industrielle
mais la révolution écologique qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
et surtout comment rendre les enfants
acteurs de cette révolution c'est très
difficile de parler de l'école notre
pays nous avons été des élèves
nous sommes des parents nous connaissons
des enseignants nous avons tous à un
avis sur cette question n'est ce pas
tout simplement incroyable qu'on n'ose
encore demandé à l'école de réparer seul
les dégâts de 30 ans de crise la
situation nous la connaissons des
réformes qui s'empilent et qui arrive
d'en haut sans concertation une pression
de plus en plus forte sur les enfants et
sur les enseignants avec des
conséquences très graves
un échec scolaire massif chez des
enfants humiliés cas c'est qu'ils n'ont
plus confiance en eux mêmes une grande
souffrance les enseignants qui aimerait
beaucoup aider leurs élèves qui ont le
sentiment de ne pas pouvoir le faire
et puis une énorme colère à l'égard de
la hiérarchie à l'égard des
gouvernements qui se succèdent et qui
donne l'impression de charger encore et
encore la barque alors les solutions
nous les connaissons et nous avons envie
de les mettre
oeuvres d'abord commencé à accompagner
les familles dès les toutes premières
années un service public de la petite
enfance est indispensable ensuite revoir
et alléger les programmes scolaires tout
n'est pas prioritaire nous devons faire
en sorte que nos enfants aient des
fondations solides pour leur permettre
ensuite de se préparer à des
orientations et des choix différents en
cours de la vie nous devons cesser de
sélectionner par l'échec retarder le
moment de la sélection et faire en sorte
que l'orientation ne soit pas faite par
défaut mais en fonction des goûts des
priorités et des besoins bien sûr aussi
du marché du travail
nous devons rompre avec un discours qui
laisse croire que nous non plus à ceux
qui ont moins alors que c'est exactement
l'inversé qui se produit et puis nous
devons permettre aux enseignants de se
recentrer sur leur mission première
enseigne et en faisant entrer d'autres
adultes dans l'école des assistants
d'éducation pour accompagner tous les
temps de la vie scolaire des éducateurs
pour permettre aux enfants handicapés
d'être accueillis effectivement comme le
prévoit la loi mais aussi des
enseignants de langues régionales
des militants associatifs des
représentants des réseaux de l'éducation
populaire c'est cette diversité qui va
permettre à l'école de ne pas être
fermés sur la vie et d'assumer aussi sa
mission culturelle et sa mission
citoyenne en tant que médecin
généraliste je suis de plus en plus
confrontés à des patients qui se posent
des questions sur les nouveaux risques
que ce soit sur la pollution les ogm ou
la grippe aviaire
j'aimerais bien savoir quelles sont les
réponses que la révolution écologique
peut apporter à ces nouveaux risques
je suis moi même médecin je partage
largement vos préoccupations la
quasi-totalité des nouvelles maladies
des nouveaux risques sont liés aux
conditions de vie et de travail aux
conditions d'environnement plus
largement c'est vrai pour la grippe
aviaire largement liée aux conditions
dans les élevages c'est vrai aussi pour
les ogm dont les risques ne sont pas
réellement très bien connu à cette heure
alors nous avons le choix entre deux
stratégies soit réparé les dégâts en
cherchant pour chaque pathologie
nouvelle une molécule miracle soit
mettre en place une stratégie
de précaution de prévention pour réduire
dans l'environnement
les facteurs qui expliquent la
dégradation de la santé pour être très
concret est-ce que nous allons continuer
à chercher une pilule miracle contre
l'obésité ou conseiller un bon équilibre
alimentaire et la pratique d'un exercice
physique régulier
est ce que nous allons dire aux
agriculteurs qui souffrent de stérilité
ou de problèmes immunitaires que ils
doivent tolérer accepter les pesticides
ou est-ce que nous allons réduire l'
usage de ces molécules toxiques dans les
pratiques agricoles
nous souhaitons donc privilégier la
prévention l'éducation sanitaire
remettre le généraliste au coeur du
système de santé ce qui suppose qu'on
travaille sur les conditions de son
installation dans les quartiers
difficiles dans les zones rurales y
compris financièrement ce qui suppose
aussi qu'on développe des nouvelles
modalités d'exercice des maisons
médicales des raisons de santé des
centres de santé où les professionnels
et les usagers pourraient travailler
ensemble
l'enjeu est tout simple il s'agit de
passer d'un système de soins qui
fonctionne au profit les professionnels
un système de santé
conçu dans l'intérêt de chacun d'entre
nous
[Musique]